Transcriber: Aseel Makahleh
المدقّق: Nada Ghannoum
(موسيقى).
TEDx
من هم الموجودون هنا اليوم؟
أصحاب الأفكار،
الجميلة.
أصحاب المبادرات.
[لمى الشريف]
أصحاب القضايا.
لكن ما الذي يجمعنا؟
يا أولو الألباب.
يخطبنا الخالق المالك الكريم
بخاصية عقولنا
فيُميّز بيننا وبين باقي الخلق.
فماذا فعلنا بذلك؟
ماذا فعلنا بتلك الخاصية؟
التي ميّز بها إلهنا نحن عن باقي الخلق.
عندما ننظر إلى العقل وطريقة تفكيرنا
نجد أنه حقيقةً
لا أستطيع أن أعرف إذا أنا مُهمِل لأفكاري
أو مُهمِل لعقلي أم لست مُهمِل
لأنه لا يوجد أثر ملموس لذلك الإهمال
إذا قُلت لك أنك مُهمِل لسيارتك
أنا أستطيع أن أقول لك أو أبرهن لك
أن السيارة وسخة، مخدوشة
أو لم تُغيّر الزيت
إذا أنا أقول لك أنك مُهمل بصحتك
عندي برهان، أستطيع أن أقول
لك أن عضلاتك تتلاشى
وزنك يزداد، مناعتك تقل
ولكن ما هي آثار الإهمال في دماغنا
البعيد عن العين، بعيدٌ عن القلب
فما لا نراه، نسوء استخدامنا له
فنُسَمم تفكيرنا ونخضع للأفكار المتدوالة
والمفاهيم الخاطئة
ونقطع طريقنا للعلم بعد تخرجنا
ونخضع لسوء الظن والتفكير السلبي
والتفرقة بين الناس
وهذا كلّه ونحن أولو الألباب
فإذا نظرنا إلى دماغنا
نجد أن الحيوان
لديه جذع الدماغ والمخيخ
وهم المسؤولين عن وظائف الحياة
الغريزة والحواس الخمسة
وهم المسؤولين عن الاستقامة والتوازن،
ولكن الإنسان لديه
أجزاء من الدماغ مطوّرة أكثر
فلديه الدماغ
الذي فيه الفص الصدغي، والبصري
والأمامي، والجداري
هذه هي الأجزاء من الدماغ
التي تساعدنا
في إن كانت العاطفة أو الاستيعاب
والتفكير والتدبّر والذاكرة
فكيف نستخدمه؟
وإذا هذا ليس كافٍ
فدماغنا في قمتنا
في قمة الشيء نفسه،
فهو أهم شيء.
والله سبحانه وتعالى اهتم فيه
من ناحيه جسدية
فأحاطه بغشاء،
وبالسائل النخاعي الشوكي،
ومن ثم بالجمجة،
فكان سليم جسدياً
ولكن كيف نحميه فكرياً من التلوث الفكري؟
نحن في شبابنا -مؤسسة استشارية-
هنا اليوم لكي نذكّركم بذلك الكنز الثمين.
نقول لكم أن الله سبحانه وتعالى
أعطانا هذا الكنز الثمين كهبة،
فكيف نحن سنستخدم هذا الكنز؟
هذه الهبة التي لم تجعلنا على أربع أرجل
مثل الكلب أو الظب أو السحلية
فارتقى بنا الله سبحانه وتعالى
فكيف استخدمناه؟
في شبابنا -مؤسسة استشارية-
أنشأنا فيلم وثائقي اسمه الباب.
هدفه مناقشة هذه القضايا.
وما نتكلم فيه هو ستة مواضيع:
نتكلم عن التركيز والتحليل.
من التركيز نتكلم عن كيف أن الإنسان
لا يتسطيع أن يصل إلى أي شيء
إلا وعنده خاصية التركيز
التركيز على الهدف،
التركيز على الشيء الواحد
حتى يصل إلى اتقانه.
التحليل وأن أي موضوع لا يُفهم
إلا من خلال التحليل بمستوياته،
والتحليل المدرّج، حتى تصل
إلى الاستيعاب الأكثر.
التعليم الذاتي والقراءة،
ونتكلم عن أهمية التعليم المستمر
وفي العقل.
التعليم في نفس المكان،
في الحُصين -جزء في الدماغ-
يسبب السعادة.
فكيف يمكن أن نصل إلى التعليم
لنصل إلى الارتقاء الفكري والسعادة.
الانتماء والعنصرية.
ووجدنا أنه في دماغنا،
يوجد جزء من الدماغ
يساعدنا في تصنيف الأشخاص.
ولكن هذه الجزئية من الدماغ
لم تُخلق لتوليد العنصرية،
إنما للتشجيع بالانتماء للقبيلة
أو الجهة أو العائلة
المفاهيم الخاطئة.
ونتكلم في المفاهيم الخاطئة
عن كيف أنه، عصبياً منذ صغرنا
نجد أننا نستقبل الأفكار قبل أن ننشئها،
حيث أننا نحن في مرحلة استقبال.
ففي هذه المرحلة نحن نكوّن شبكات،
شبكات كهربائية في دماغنا،
هذه الشبكات الكهربائية تكوّن الفكرة.
فعصبياً أنت عندما يكون لديك فكرة
في دماغك مترسخة في الأصل،
أسهل لدماغك أن يرجع للشبكات المنشئة
بدلاً من أن يٌنشئ شبكات جديدة.
فعندما نتكلم عن المفاهيم الخاطة
وطريقة معالجتها
نجد أنها صعبة حتى عصبياً لنا،
لأنه يجب أن نعود ونراجع أنفسنا،
ونكسر الشبكات القديمة وننشئ شبكات جديدة.
الذاكرة، نتكلم عن الثلاثة مراحل للذاكرة
التي هي: التشفير ثم التخزين ثم الاسترجاع.
وكيف يمكن أن نتمكّن من كل هذه المراحل،
حتى نصل إلى تقوية ذاكرتنا
فأنت لا تستطيع أن تسترجع معلومة
لم تقم بتشفيريها أو تخزينها بشكل صحيح
فكيف يمكن أن نقوم بهذا الشيء؟
وكيف يمكن أن نتعلّم ونستفيد من هذا الشيء
لكي نطوّر عقلنا ونستخدمه لأقصى درجة.
العاطفة والضغط.
نحن من أكثر المجتمعات
التي تهمل الجانب النفسي من الصحة.
حتى تأميننا الصحي لا يُغطي الأمراض العقلية
لا أعلم لماذا صراحةً !
فهذا هو الشيء الذي يجب أن نهتم فيه.
لماذا؟
لأنه حتى في عقلك، عندما تنظر إلى عقلك
والعاطفة في عقلك،
تجد أنها مرتطبة بالمناعة.
فكيف لا نصل إلى معالجة المشكلة من أساسها!
ونعالجها بدلاً من ذلك في غرفة الطوارئ!
واستخدمنا كل هذه المواضيع
وقلنا كيف سوف نقدمها للشباب؟
استخدمنا عناصر مختلفة:
من جولة افتراضية في الدماغ
ومشاهد تمثيلية، ومقابلات شخصية مع مختصين.
وطبعاً في هذا الفيلم استعنا بخبرات:
أطباء، أطباء مخ وأعصاب،
أطباء نفسية.
استعنا بخبرات أساتذة علوم سياسية،
وأساتذة تنمية بشرية
حتى نخرج بهذا الفيلم.
هؤلاء بعض الأشخاص الذين كنا معهم.
- صور-
وهدفنا نحن في شبابنا -مؤسسة استشارية-
أنه لماذا نقدّم هذه المعلومة؟
لأنه وجدنا هذا الكنز
عندما بدأنا بالبحث.
ونحن في شبابنا ليس فقط أنا،
إنما مئة شاب وشابة مؤمنون بهذه القضية،
التي هي قضية تمكين الشباب من خلال التوعية.
فنحن هنا اليوم لنخبركم أن ألبابنا
واجبٌ علينا أن نصونها.
فعلينا كلنا أن نحمل ذلك الكشّاف
في تلك الغرفة المظلمة،
وننير كل زاوية فيها.
ونبدأ رحلتنا في الثقافة والعلم والمعرفة.
ونبدأ بأجسادنا وبعقولنا،
حتى نفهم خلقنا من ذلك الخالق المالك الكريم
ونتعجب منه.
وبتلك الخطوة نبدأ بنهضة أمتنا
من خلال نهضة ألبابها.
شكراً
(تصفيق)
(موسيقى)